et c'est qu'isabelle bruna rieuse qui
est avec nous en duplex depuis besançon
beaux jours isabelle bonjour pascal
journaliste chez nous est alors de la
transition écologique france 3 bourgogne
franche comté participe au débat sur
l'avenir de l'agriculture en diffusant
justement votre documentaire qui
s'appelle entre deux mondes
c'est aujourd'hui ça se passe après le
soir 3 alors juste avant d'en découvrir
un petit extrait isabelle comment vous
est venue l'idée de ce film finalement
alors ça remonte en fait à une rencontre
avec denis michaud qui est un
agriculteur enseignants à levier c'est
lui qui m'a dit qu'en 2014 il y avait eu
une réforme de l'enseignement agricole
et que maintenant les élèves apprenaient
à produire autrement alors produire
autrement ça veut dire produire en
respectant l'environnement
du coup je me suis dit c'est intéressant
peut-être de suivre des étudiants et de
voir à comment se passe cette c'est
enseignements qu'ils reçoivent en cours
et quand ils rentrent chez eux ou chez
leurs maîtres de stage comment ça se
passe parce que eux les parents les
grands parents n'avaient pas forcément
la rue le même enseignement et donc je
me suis dit ça serait intéressant de
voir comment l'évolution se fait voilà
de confondre parfait et isabelle juste
avant de savoir comment ces étudiants
s'apprêtent à vivre cette transition
écologique
je vous propose de regarder ce qui va se
passer tout à l'heure après soir 3 avec
un petit extrait de ce documentaire qui
s'appelle entre deux mondes regardez je
m'appelle antoine moïse
donc j'ai 18 ans je suis en actuellement
en bts axe à lever axe veut dire
analyses conduites et stratégies
d'exploitation
aujourd'hui je voudrais découvrir une
autre façon de faire qui est différent
de chez moi
pour pro quérir de l'expérience très
bien
non
m'appelle alice qu'un champ je suis
embêté sax à levier j'habite dans le
doubs puisque je veux m'installer plus
tard j'estimais que c'était important de
faire un peu de la gestion un peu
d'élevage et un peu d'accalmie en même
temps qu'est ce qui se passe
bougez plus
[Musique]
quel caroline
je veux reprendre
l'exploitation familiale de mes parents
c'est une envie depuis tout petit j'ai
jamais eu d'autres envies c'est vraiment
naturel que j'aime bien ce métier n'est
dans la nature on produit quelque chose
pour nous aider j'en sais pas si ce qui
m'intéresse voilà
[Musique]
ils ont la vie devant eux et notre
avenir entre leurs mains
ces jeunes ont choisi de préparer un bts
agricole travailler pour nous nourrir
tout en préservant la planète
c'est leur défi est celui de l'agro
écologie
[Musique]
entre les habitudes héritées de leurs
familles et l'enseignement de méthodes
innovantes
ils sont entre deux mondes alors comment
ces étudiants s'apprête-t-il à vivre
cette transition écologique c'est ce que
nous découvrirons dans votre film ce
sera après le soir 3 isabelle mais pas
seulement finalement parce que ce qu'on
sait pas forcément c'est que c'est un
triple projet isabelle oui alors non
seulement j'ai travaillé avec jean
michel beau et thomas hardy et puis
françois tourtes et pour la partie film
mais j'ai travaillé aussi avec le
photographe bisontin yves petit à petit
je voulais qu'ils apportent cette ce
point de vue en fait se portent les
portraits des jeunes qui allaient
évoluer forcément en deux ans et ya rien
de mieux que la photographie pour se
rendre compte de l'évolution d'une
personne alors du coup il m'a dit mais
si on faisait un livre alors j'ai dit
banco donc avec yves petit et le
graphiste stéphane langelier on a fait
ce livre voilà qui sort qui est sorti
dans lequel il ya aussi la possibilité
de voir le documentaire est là ce qui
est intéressant c'est que donc on peut
aller plus loin puisqu'il ya aussi la
parole des enseignants qui nous parle de
la façon dont ils transmettent
l'agroécologie et la tousart encore fait
boule de neige puisque yves me dit petit
me dit et si on faisait une exposition
alors je lui dis bah ok on cherche un
lieu on trouve la maison du des maisons
compte le musée des maisons comtoises à
tout à côté de besançon à l'encré et du
coup il y aura aussi tout cet été une
exposition avec la parole de ces huit
jeunes et les photographies d'yves petit
et c'est donc à une façon de prolonger
le film est d'engager surtout un débat
de société sur la façon dont nous la
société nous pouvons aider ces jeunes à
réaliser cette transition agro
écologiques
alors il ya le film il ya le livre qu'on
vient de voir et à l'expo on a compris
isabelle on se dit maintenant forcément
l' aventure continue vous nous avez fait
le tiercé pour le quarté + qu'est ce que
vous nous réservez en quelques secondes
pour entre deux mondes pour la suite
pour nous enfin je pense qu'il faudra
dans quelques années est retourné voir
ces jeunes qui seront devenus adultes
et puis se rendre compte si
ils ont pu mettre en place cette
nouvelle façon de produire autrement
merci isabelle en tout cas rendez vous
tout à l'heure après le soir 3 spécial
s'il ya aussi une rediffusion vendredi 5
juillet ce sera juste avant nous
justement ce sera la dernière pour nous
le 5 juillet ce sera aux alentours de
9h15 et puis bien sûr sur le site de
france 3 bourgogne franche comté ou
pourquoi pas les écrans connectés